what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
kevin samuels clip
labeled these men ain't on my level
now i'm just gonna predict now that it's
gonna be a woman with like
three kids from two different dads
overweight saying that she deserves a
guy making 500k
i don't know but i've seen a theme in
these videos before i start do not
forget to like comment and subscribe
let me know in the comments how like
what level you think this woman's on i
haven't even watched it don't know what
she looks like
but just let me know
20 20. all right uh
the question tonight is your why are
they always sitting in bed
that irritates me so much stand up
go somewhere
no my price is way too low
why are you saying i pay for everything
vacation about the country
car notes i pay for everything
i'm in college my daddy makes six
figures
i'm still dressed right here let me
start where are you getting this money
my daddy so your daddy pays for
everything
yeah yeah
so
why are you allowing your dad to pay for
he you know man he doesn't know
yet he doesn't know basically like i get
an
allowance every week okay
and is she one of those girls that says
i pay my own bills but
her dad pays for everything these men
they just nod to my standards so it's
like okay you're not gonna be there
i'm gonna make you be there wait what
what do you mean what do you mean
they're not to your standard what does
that mean
i'm in college i go to penn state they
not in college they on the block
i live in a high-rise apartment
i get it i get it you got stuff you all
let the bag of chips got it
but what i'm trying to understand is a
father who can provide an income for his
daughter to have a weekly allowance
you go to one of the best colleges in
the country
why the french toast are you dealing
with [ __ ] on the block
it's where i grew up anyways i don't
care i don't care
what does that mean that's what you grew
up well then leave penn state and carry
your ass back to the block
get off your daddy's payroll and then go
live in the in section eight how about
that
i don't want to you of course i can't
wait to young lady's trying to grow up
damn you sound spoiled damn
that's why i need you no no but but well
what you need to stop
doing is stop talking like you got
something
damn you got nothing in this world young
lady
father
what the audacity what high income
skills do you have
um i'm certified um i'm a certified
computer programmer and i'm certified in
five different coding languages
okay then one parent with 18 okay okay
not the case that's the case who's
paying for college
my father did you since you have these
high income skills
why don't you pay for it yourself i
haven't graduated yet
so we're gonna do this this way [ __ ] if
you get free college
i don't care who you are nobody's gonna
pay for it yourself if you don't have to
okay
even i don't try to be overly moral but
this is you know this is wrong
you're allowing your father to work like
to work to put himself into a position
where you're keeping your you're
deceiving you're keeping this from your
father
because you know it's wrong right
so if you're gonna do wrong you should
at least pay for your own wrong
okay about how these being in on your
level okay so
i don't know the stuff when you when
you're openly bypassing the guys on the
university campus
to go pick dudes from the block because
that's what your mindset is
damn here's the thing i've tried the
whole dating
they didn't do on my level in college
i bet you she doesn't get a lot of
attention at her college i bet you
that's why she goes to the guys on the
block
they're a narcissist they're narcissists
no no
no ma'am see
how many young ladies man where's your
mom
my mom's an accountant she she loves you
i said where's your mom but you called
up you called somebody a narcissist
there are three components to being a
narcissist
okay
i expect you to call things what they
are
okay honestly
it doesn't sound to me like you are
mentally mature enough to be dating
anyone
so here's my thing i've been in a
relationship now for
since july so but that's going on nine
months now
i haven't had this problem the problem i
have now
is that i don't have a problem with
spending money on him because he's got
his own but the problem i have now is
i'm in college i'm getting ready to
graduate from penn state
all right he not in school
he works so minimal his job which which
is fine because i don't i don't judge
but i want a life for him and i
don't know what to do because i just
know i already know how
this is what you do this is what you do
you want to be rebellious
uh you allow me to send your father this
videotape
this video you let your father watch
this video
and let your mother watch this video and
let them cut you off
damn you want to be grown be grown
you think you know better do better with
your five
and all this other stuff let's do it
let's see that how that really works
let's see if love conquers all the
minimum wage how about that
i mean eleventh i mean what you want me
to tell you
love conquest i don't believe that i
believe that this is a damn shame
that mother and fathers have put
themselves black mothers and fathers to
put themselves in a position to put
their daughter in one of the best
schools
in the in the country and this is the
outcome
and you know better i did
i could i grew up in jack and jill but
but but
but the sex is just that good right it's
not the same
it can't be nothing else
it can't be nothing else that's i mean
you're talking to a grown man it can't
be nothing else this dude ain't
talk about on your level you went you
decided to go to the block and pull a
dude to make makes minimum wage what
else you got
this one i didn't pull from the block
this one i didn't
well um sadly man it's probably because
she can't get a guy that's
on that level if you're being serious
um i hope you're using lots of
protection because
you women like yourself end up usually
end up as baby mamas
and then by about 30 years old after you
have the second kid you blaming me
i don't want to do that i don't want to
do well then like i said
the woman i'm talking to right now is
not mentally mature enough to be in a
relationship with man
you need to grow up
okay i'm gonna take your advice because
you know what you're talking about
someone listen to what
what's your your degrees in some sort of
computer science or something like that
right no actually i'm a
political science major and what do you
plan on doing with that degree
um going to law school
yeah exactly all right
okay um well first thing i would say
is um how tall are you
four eleven dress size size eight
huh eight uh you look a little
like i have a round face i don't have a
pancake
i'm looking at your ankles and your
fingers i'm not looking at them
look at me on my page i'm good i'm good
i do this in real life
but what i'm saying is focus on
one living a more fit life to
being around women and the kind and
calorie of men that can help you get to
the level of maturity you need to be
because i don't understand what the
disconnect is
but young lady you're 20 yeah
you are an adult you're an adult and
you're making adult decisions
and every time you choose to have
intercourse with these people
you're risking pregnancy
um and it pregnancies at least in your
concern
stds and all this other kind of stuff
relationships are for adults
and that's not that's not a that's not a
bad thing
i mean when you start talking about
spending money and trips and travel and
things like that
that's grown folk stuff right you know
pizza
and movies and holding hands and necking
so um i think you know what you need to
do i think you just don't want to do
that
uh but uh if you're gonna you're gonna
do it this way spend your money not your
daddy's
how about that though you're right all
right peace out
okay she actually let me pause
us okay she looked like she
somewhat was listening to him
i bet you she just doesn't feel like she
can get a guy
like anywhere else i bet you that's why
she's with him but let me know in the
comments what you think her issue was
and what you think that she could do to
improve her situation for the future
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe
talk to you guys later